Want to turn now to some last
minute drama
in the Fox News defamation case.
That trial was supposed to start today,
but it has been delayed.
And CNN watched as lawyers
for Dominion
voting systems brought more than 40 boxes
into the courthouse today,
most likely evidence and other materials.
CNN's Oliver Dorsey joins us now.
He's outside the courthouse
in Wilmington, Delaware.
Oliver, what is happening
some 11th hour,
11th hour twist
really casting in a question
of whether a trial, John,
is even going to take place.
Right behind me,
was where it's supposed to have started.
Opening arguments
were supposed to be taking place
right about now.
But last night, the judge abruptly
delayed the trial, saying
it's going to now start on Tuesday.
And there's no reason
given the judge said today
that he doesn't find it
unusual for this
to have been delayed by one day.
But Rupert Murdoch's
Wall Street
Journal as well, as some other outlets
now reporting that
a last minute
settlement might be in the works,
that Fox might be pushing
to settle this case,
avert a trial
and really spare
some of its high profile
talent and executives like Rupert Murdoch
from having to take the stand
and testify
as to why they allowed
election lies to be broadcast on Fox,
despite knowing that they were not true.
Now, both sides are still preparing
for a trial.
The judge said
basically to be back tomorrow
and a trial will start
if a settlement is not reached.
Dominion
brought in about 40 boxes
earlier of evidence into the courtroom.
So they're clearly ready, John,
to go to trial.
If a settlement is not reached.
Right now, everything
sort of seems just up in the air,
up in the air.
We'll see how the negotiations
go behind closed doors.
Oliver, keep us posted.
If anything, changes.
Let's bring in our senior legal analyst,
Ellie Hoenig.
Good morning.
There's so much on the table here. Twist.
I know the plot thickens.
What a twist.
Why would a judge do this?
Well, so if you go to a judge in either
a criminal or civil case
on the eve of trial
and say we're making close progressions
towards a settlement
or in a criminal case,
this is not a criminal case
towards a guilty plea.
Often judges will say, okay,
I'll give you a day,
I'll give you two days,
maybe I'll give you a week.
I'll give you a chance to work it out.
I think that's the most likely scenario
we've seen reporting consistent
with that as well.
So you think there's
you think there's probably
those hawks somewhere going,
yeah, there's something about
being on the eve of trial
that can really sober up both parties.
It's a reality, right?
Look, look at it.
From Fox's point of view,
they're looking
at the likelihood,
if there's a trial
of having all of
there are many of their
most prominent anchors
have to take the stand, testify
and get cross-examined.
So and the owners
and the top executive executives,
they're up to
and including Rupert Murdoch.
And so you can understand why
they would be hit
by reality at the last moment,
say we need to avoid this.
And, you know,
another question is,
why would Dominion be interested
in potentially settling this?
Because as we've discussed,
I think Dominion has a very
strong case here for defamation.
But the fact of the matter is,
nothing's sure when it comes to a jury.
There's always risk
when it comes to a jury trial.
Juries, just 12 human beings,
you never know what they're going to do.
So if if there is a settlement.
Help us understand,
because it's beyond
how much money they settle for
which I think
gets a disproportionate amount
of attention.
But how much is a lot of do
I and I understand that.
I think also the company
has a lot of money.
What I think is fascinating,
if there is a settlement,
is does it
come with an admission of guilt,
an apology? Right.
Or an admission of wrongdoing?
So there's a couple of things
that are in play here
if there's a negotiation.
First of all, of course,
there's the amount parties
will go back and forth on that.
Second of all, there's
will this be confidential?
Usually settlements like this
are confidential.
We don't know the numbers
unless we get it through reporting,
but we wouldn't know it officially.
But the parties are free to negotiate.
This number will
or will not be confidential.
And then the parties can negotiate
for any sort
of admission of guilt,
statement, acknowledgment,
retraction, etc.
But keep in mind,
the judge here has already made a finding
as a matter of law
that Fox his statements
about the 2020 election
and about Dominion were false.
So that is on the record.
The only question
that trial was going to be
Is there actual malice?
Did Fox know
or were they reckless about the falsity?
So no matter what
Dominion has that finding a falsity.
Okay.
So then 1.6 million, you're right.
It's a lot of money for the foxes
deep pockets, right?
Yes.
And their viewers
will probably not believe
that they did anything wrong,
that they were targeted, you know.
So I'm not sure what it does
to their credibility.
Right.
Because it's kind of, you know, well,
the facts are out there, right?
We've all seen the text.
They're all out there
and we have the funding from the judge.
Okay.
So the $1.6 billion,
if they go to court and they win,
are they likely to get that?
And if they settle,
how much money are we talking?
So I don't think there was
any realistic chance of Dominion
getting $1.6 billion
in compensatory damages,
meaning the amount
we were damage, the amount
we have to be paid
back to get us back to zero.
The entire company,
by its own
valuation, is worth anywhere
from 30 to $80 million,
but that's not even 10% of $1.6 billion.
Yes, dominion is worth it.
So from Dominion's
point of view,
I think
$1.6 billion was always
a very optimistic, optimistic ask now.
Keep in mind though,
they could also get punitive damages.
And so Fox is looking at this.
They're saying, okay, Dominion's
asking for $1.6 billion
to compensate them,
but also punitive damages on top.
So again,
you can see the high end risk
that Fox will be running at a trial here.
So don't go on vacation this weekend.
All right.
And then Fox will see what
also apologizing to that judge for.
Right.
Well, they got in trouble with the
with the judge
on a couple of big issues last week
that could incentivize them to.
Thank you, Ali.